all week long
what have i been saying i've been saying
this is the person who's going to steal
the show of course this is the person
who's going to steal the show
i got to tell you i am i am so excited
and we've been really working
i want to say this the whole show it's
the show as a whole that works there's
so many great
performances and entertainers and
i think will has done something to
really make people feel like oh we're
celebrating movies not just movies we
don't know like we're celebrating movies
we've got
so who do we have we have um
we have uh francis for copeland tonight
they're so
there's so many people so i get to
return to real deal hollywood yes
finally yes so will packer came up here
a little bit ago and this is how this
man walked up here
dancing happy chilling i know this show
is good i'm dancing that's what it is
that's well no i want to i've seen will
in press conferences and everything else
he is so calm
so clear on what he wants
and so steady and i think the great part
about that is because
he's you know in charge it's that that
energy flows down to us
so you know his steadiness keeps
everybody steady tell us about the
womanhood on this stage tonight you
wanda amy i mean
it just makes me smile thinking about
the three of you all yeah you know it is
it's i mean i'm i'm such a fan of both
of them i'd known wanda before and like
the chance to play with wanda i was so
excited about it and
you know it's um
it's one of those things where it's like
when they were like trying to get to the
host where i said so i said wanda i said
ain't nobody pick one of us like you
think they're gonna be really sad when
they find out or they're gonna be like
frank wait how'd they get those three
but we were really excited that's what i
wanted to ask you what was that moment
like when you got the call and said
you're gonna host the oscars
you know what it's wonderful it's scary
too you know it's intimidating it's
exciting it's it's
it's every emotion you would expect to
have because there's um there's so many
eyes on it you know
where they used to be so we'll see what
happens tonight do you feel a little
more comfortable though with will
because this is i mean you've done six
movies together it's almost like you're
his muse
i mean he's your yeah you're his muse in
a lot of ways yeah yeah no i think it
did you know it was one of the things
that made it definitely comfortable to
sign on you know will is so open
collaborative smart you know what i mean
very um
in touch he and sayla um with what's
happening you know what i mean and i
think that's what made us feel like oh
you know it's going to be a different
oscars he's coming to
to bring some levity all right real
quick before you go how many outfit
changes
and i just want to tell you woman to
woman sister sister i'm so glad to see
you getting your flowers and this
opportunity you deserve it i really do
so much thank you so much so much so i
hope i hope to make all of y'all proud
you will you will i know you're going
before you leave tell us about this
dress this dress is very wang and it
just was i just loved it it was like
i don't know i'm a brown girl i wore a
brown dress you know
and i just thought it was very romantic
have a blast tonight reggie have fun